こんにちは
在校生ではありません卒業生ですね
a
今日僕は13年ぶりに10校に行きました
すごい久しぶりです2002年に文学部フランス文学科卒業したんですが
なのでちょっとこれだけは言わせてください
おかえりなれっ
赤い缶ありがとうございます
この中で
在校生を努力台いらっしゃいますか
意外と少ないですねじゃあ ob og の方
ありがとうございますあとはその他の方 ob og の方の中で
大学の専攻と今の仕事が微妙に違う
あるいは今して一括で c た仕事がちょっと違うなっていうかどれぐらいしますか
先行と違う仕事をしていたしている
その中で後ろめたいなそれって感じだったことがあることはどれ位いらっしゃいますか
いらっしゃいますねありがとうございますなんでこんなことを聞いたのかと言うと実は
僕自身がそういう思いを持っていたからです
フランス文学科を卒業した僕ですが最初に勤めた仕事は web でないな
でした
それはまっすぐに大学の専攻を生かせる仕事ではありませんでしょう
あんまり検索てもいいのかもしれないですけど
まあ大学に親が他にを出してくれてきた
いろんなことを考えるとどうしても引きずるところがあって
心残りをたくさんありました
でもきょう中3年ぶりにこの場に立っていることをとても感慨深く思っています
さらに来年から京都にある大学の人文学部で先生を塗ることが決まりました
なので
卒業者13年なんで行っ東
その後ろめたい気持ちがなんか来なくなってきて親にも
大学がありがとっていいますから言えるみたいなそんな感じになっています
たのでただいまと言うのは本当に僕にとって大きな意味があります
忘れ物を取りに来たというか
本物じゃ is 別に例えの話ですよ
あるいはぽっかり空いていたピースが埋まったよ
ペットそれって何
自分かつての自分あるいは大事なルーツともう1回出会えたからその喜びなんじゃない
かなと
ていて今日はレビューニューウェイズマッパースター
ちゃんってカッコよくてくださいってお願いしたんですがかつての自分ともう一度再開
する
そんなテーマで少しお話しできたかなと思う
ています
僕の今の肩書きはグリーンズ. jp の編集長です
今まではですね web サーバー
アートディレクタークリエイティブデザイナーとかでありますけど
くれて見ていられたということで横文字の仕事をたくさんできます
それは秋田出身の僕が
地元に入っ帰ったらシェア増やされる仕事をしたいと
そういう基準で選んでみましょうん
ちなみにでも web デザイナーの3町
お勧めてくれたのは今もフランス軍学科の先生を務める
澤田肇教授です
てる人いるかな
多分澤田先生覚えてないと思うんですが
e ラーニングの授業をしたいということで学生の中から web デザイナーを募集
したんですね
web デザイナーかっこいいへ
やります
っていうので僕はて終わりました
そしたらあまりにも面白くてハマってしまったんです
その頃稼いだお金は
visual book って結構破壊じゃないですか
1万円とかするようなそういうのばっかりつぎ込んでいました
というのもデザインをちゃんと学んでいる美大生にすごくプレイスがあったんですよ
でも僕はもうどこ後独学でやるんだと心に決めて
本当に初期杖道の幸
溢れんばかりに異論自分のホームページを作ってみましょう
そのホームページ頭に海外の地球の裏側にする海岸じゃないから
お前の英語はでたらめだがセンスはいいみたいな不思議な映像いただいたりと思う
そんなこともあってずっとその当時は若気の至りもたくさんあるんですが作ること
デザインすることにのめり込んでいました
なので
文学部なんですが本は全くほっ
本という形ぞ文字の本は全く読まず
フランス文学科とちゃダメな生徒で
あの
これ
あそこで僕の作品ですどうよ
これ今は亡きコンピュータールームのプリンターなんですけどこれもカッコイーカッコ
いいなこれ
思ってたんで僕はとんね
で8
これはいまも最初に残っているんですが僕の卒論テーマで他の有名な
5分学者の名前がある中で僕はパリのと白について帰って来てそれがもうずっと残って
いる
ちょっと恥ずかしいそんな感じです
でも今そういうで大畑出身になった僕が言葉の道に今住んでいます
そう天気だったのがこの屋久島の風景
太鼓岩と呼ばれるもののけの森をちょっと抜けたところにある一枚
すっごいは勝手
ここはそこに東山行った時
もうすごく感動したんですね
その感動を言葉でつづっていたです
詩を書いてたんですん
北半田気づいちゃったんですね
僕は感動したら絵を描くんじゃないんだ
言葉なんだと
曽野木1月はですね僕の道を極めました
デザイナーを諦めました
で言葉の道に過剰切りました
その翌年2006年にグリーンズが創刊されます
おかげさまで来年10周年を迎えます
なぜ話スマホからも見えます
僕がグリーンズで
編集として何をしたいかというと編集とは情報発信を通じてご縁を育んのことだと思っ
ています
一つ一つの記事がきっかけになって活動の信用度が高まったとか
それによって良い仲間が見つかったか
さまざまな活動に取り組んでいるたちのサポートをメディアとして
できたらいいなと思っています
その主役が約100名のグリーンズ誇るライターさん達です
ライターさんたちは贈り物を届けるようにラベルたを書くように1本1本の記事を丁寧
に書いてくれています
もう一つ一つの記事が大きな練り御生んでいる
そんな彼らの姿を見ていると
言葉の力を駆使して世界に貢献する仕事というのは無限の可能性があるんだな
僕自身が学ばせてもらっています
それは
人文系ソーシャルイノベーター
今はかなきゃですという新しい可能性です
一方で
編集者とかライターの仕事というのは今実は買い叩かれてたりしています
次記事100円で大量生産大量消費されるセク
そうなると人文系の仕事は稼げない
みたいに若い世代にとって魅力のない仕事に移ってしまっているかもしれません
加えて
今経済性ばかりを追いかけてしまうと
人間とは何か
社会はどうあれべく
そういうことを掘り下げる人文学が社会の中で
結構
脇道にを得られてそんな風潮さえ感じています
でもそんな今だからこそ僕はグリーンズの編集長として
言葉の表現者であるか規定の仕事にもっと命を吹き込みたいなと
持っているんです
それはベストセラー作家を育てるのかそういうことだけではなくて
街に必ずパン屋さんが数件あるように
近所に必ずライターさんや編集者が住んでいて
その方々がいることで街の魅力がどんどん発信されていったり
あるいは近所の子供たちに文章力日本語を教える
こんな氷室を開いてもいいかも知れませ
あるいはそれ位でやりたいと思ってもらえるようなコンセプトを作ることだったり
あるいは物語をきちんと伝えてその商品の良さを伝えたり
言葉の力で世界がいつのまにか暮らしやすくなっている
それが僕が考える人文系ソーシャルイノベーターのあり方です
実額で私学でもい学園件合格でもいい
日本上代文学日本の食精子でも階段を集めた雪は天祥閣でもなんでもいいです
それにソーシャルデザインを掛け算したい
皆さんが人生をかけて取り組んでいる研究テーマと今の現場の社会の問題がリンクした
ときにどんな反応が起こるのか
僕が来年京都で始まる仕事はそんな越境の現場です
僕自身もちなみに空海とそうじゃないというテーマで研究を進めています
空海中の平安時代に生きた
今週を開い東郷さんで宗教家としてだけなく
運ゲーや書道後様々な廃炉に恵まれていて俺をじゃあレオナルドダヴィンチのような
万能型の制裁と言われていたりします
社会的な医療もたくさん
ま+103の実績があってまさに僕が考えるその当時を代表する
人文系ソーシャルイノベーターなんですね
そんな空海はこんなことを言っています
世界的な課題を解決するためのアイディアのパ年はすでに私たちの中にある
世界を眺める見方さえ変えれば誰もがそれに気付くことができる
1200年も前のそんな言葉を
インスピレーション溢れるそんな発見を今の時代にどう具体的に応用できるか
僕自身そんなことを明らかにしながら
人文系ソーシャルイノベーターのあり方を模索していきたいなと
思っています
めぐりめぐって
京都を舞台に
新しい仕事につくわけですがこれは僕にとって大事な
原点回帰だと思っている
大学生の頃に置き忘れてきた文学と
今年になってやっと向き合い
で思うと最近こういう自分との差異化がずっと続いてるなぁと思ってすごく不思議なん
だ
思っています
空間を初めて知ったのは実は24歳の時でした
意味がわからなかった
でもなんだか惹かれた
そしたら早急に歳になったときに
分かってきた分かってないですよわかってきた
っと
で
文学と向き合い方にすごく迷っていたハタチを自分
と36歳にして向き合っていっ
このままいったら
高校生の時に憧れたファッションデザイナーそれで僕はフランス軍学校を選んだんです
けど
ファッションデザイナーという道に
40歳を超えて取り込むかもしれない
もしかしはパジャマのブランドを立ち上げているかもしれない
買ってください
あるいは小学校の文集で書いた総理大臣になりたい
という女を管理機すぎて目指せるかもしれない
かつての自分が
これから数べき道というものを用意してくれていると思うと
そんな昔の若気の至りもすごく誇らしく思います
今はちょっとだけ出来る事も増え体
ちょっとだけ成長して
一番大きいの相談できる仲間がたくさんいます
だからこそ8堤外というと現実的に向けられる
そんなことを感じています
きっとこれからも
そうだろうし
この後期しそのものが僕のこれからの人生を肯定してくれています
今日
この場でただいまって
言えたことも
きっと僕の人生の大事な一幕です
そんな感じでぜひ皆さんもかつての自分ともう一度であって
行き来する姿を僕はたくさん見たいなと思っています
今日はありがとうございました